the United Nations has said an air
strike on a migrant center in Libya that
killed at least 44 people quote amounts
to a war crime
more than 130 were wounded in the attack
in the capital Tripoli Libya is a
transit country for migrants trying to
reach Europe it's also a failed stage
riven by power struggles between various
factions now the two most important are
Libya's un-backed government which has
blamed the airstrike on the other key
faction the self-styled Libyan National
Army led by strongman Khalifa Haftar
it has denied being behind the attack
and we can speak to Charlie Yaxley UNHCR
spokesperson for Libya Charlie thank you
for joining us do you have any more
information on know what is happening
now at this migrant Center in Tripoli
well currently a rescue operation is
underway we know that at least 40 people
have died in last night's airstrikes
dozens more injured and the death toll
is in fact likely to reach even higher
as that rescue operation goes on UNHCR
teams on the ground and an our staff for
providing aid and medical care to the
survivors and they tell us that the
survivors are all deeply traumatized by
what's happened fear for what could have
happened to them I mean the thing is
here this was something that was a
easily predictable just two months ago
you and I came out calling for this
Detention Center to be evacuated after a
similar airstrike hit a roof injuring
two of the detainees and no action was
taken since we made that call and sadly
people have paid the price with their
life last night this was a horrific
attack Charlie Libya we should say is
not only a transit country it is also a
failed state that's why you have issued
those warnings there are various
factions fighting at the morning at the
moment rather should be should the
European Union really be working with
the Libyan coast guards to intercept
migrants and send them back to these
holding centers if they're not safe
but there has to be a change in approach
now that the status quo cannot continue
I mean first of all we now need to
urgently evacuate all the people who
remain in detention centers there are
still thousands in detention centers
including in Tripoli right now who are
similar risks to the people who who
suffered last night we need states to
come forward and help us evacuate people
refugees out of the country but really
the approach to the Mediterranean is key
here one of the problems we've had in
the last two months is that new people
are being brought to the detention
centers after being intercepted by the
Coast Guard faster than we can get them
out we need a shift in approach that
sees no refugee or migrant rescued on
the Mediterranean returned to Libya
there is no port in Libya that can be
considered safe for rescued refugees and
migrants at this time and Charlie tell
us more about the people who are
affected here who are these migrants and
where are they coming from I mean that's
part of the the the tragedy here many of
these people who are being detained in
appalling conditions inside these
detention centers have themselves a fled
war and violence and persecution in
their home countries there that they've
traveled through sub-saharan Africa
after falling prey to the smuggling and
trafficking networks there we hear
reports of smugglers and traffickers
committing a range of abuses including
beatings kidnaps
selling people as slaves by the time
people reach Libya they're already
deeply traumatized and with vow since
April violence having escalated
throughout Tripoli it's no surprise that
people were desperately trying to flee
this situation only to be brought back
and killed by the very same violence
they were trying to escape from and
Charlie let's come back to this strike
the UN is blaming the troops of general
Khalifa Haftar one of the factions that
we
that is a warring at the moment how did
you come to the conclusion that they
might be behind this and what would be
in it for a hosta to strike a refugee
camp
UNHCR ourselves a mandate is to work
with refugees in Libya we're not able to
independently verify exactly who carried
out the airstrike well we can say for
sure is that these coordinates of the
detention centers the exact location is
shared with the warring parties there
now needs to be a full and thorough
investigation the individuals
responsible for this attack need to be
identified and they need to be fully
held to account for this there needs to
be consequences so that this does not
happen again all right Charlie actually
a UNHCR spokesperson for Libya thank you
very much